what's up guys my name is Colin McNeill
for the score eSports a great man once
posed the question what's beef well to
answer it beef is when two people or
organizations have an ongoing mutually
disrespectful relationship so for this
top ten we scoured the eSports landscape
from halo to League of Legends to find
you the spiciest rivalries we could so
without further ado let's get on with it
here are the top 10 in sports beats
kicking off our list at number 10 is TSM
Reginald versus clg's hotshot GG the TSM
and CLG owners have fostered one of
eSports premier rivalries since 2010
when Reginald played for CL Chinese to
play with red J's to be on a team with
him and it was first short time a very
very short time their individual rivalry
quickly moved on to the rift after they
became full-time owners the beef went
public the rivalry would often include
humiliating bets
beef evolve to the point where playing
for either team meant beefing with the
other because Co J my sodium levels
go out of control they just have TSM
snuper although just for you Sam you
know as far as I know
I'm worried about his cloud 9 the rest
are non-existent
especially Co G to date TSM has won four
more na LCS splits but CLG routinely
posts strong results
CLG even beat TSM at Madison Square
Gardens in 2015 to claim an NA LCS
championship of their own a beef that
started between two former players has
had a rippling effect on the two teams a
rivalry that is still felt today hello
and welcome to the Shanghai major
presented by perfect dota twos Shanghai
major was problematic for many reasons
but one controversy that stands above
the rest is the firing of James too good
Harding which comes in at number 9 on
our list so last night you know I was
perusing the hotel entertainment it
turned out you know censorship the
Chinese hotel to say I heard the second
board pornography don't get me wrong I
watched it mr. Wang's amazing wheelchair
antics were pretty amazing you can [ __ ]
off with for his controversial
commentary valve CEO Gabe Newell made
headlines by publicly denouncing and
firing Harding calling him an ass in a
reddit post two things James we've had
issues with James at previous events
some valve people wahby to bring him
back for Shanghai feeling that he
deserved another chance that was a
mistake James is an ass and we won't be
working with him again Harding tried to
clear his name and posted screenshots of
a conversation with dota 2 developer
icefrog telling him to be himself these
days the infamous caster has retired
from the game and is playing
professional quake champions coming in
at number 8 is sniped down versus lethal
yes we are talking about a halo beef
one week before the 2016 X Games in
Aspen lethal left Evil Geniuses and
joined rival team CLG if there's one
player on eg that you feel you need to
shut down
who is that player probably sniped on
he's like the best player he's just so
sick you know I get really worried when
I see him and you know it's just the
stuff he does is insane
alright well any any words here slap
down I remember what happened last time
that exact quote was said to me so uh
watch your face
that led ng team captain sniped down to
post a tell-all YouTube video that
explained the situation I were friends I
feel like it was pretty out of the blue
I didn't really communicate well with us
at all about this best of luck for him
and whatever he decides to choose I
really hope that it comes to bite him in
the ass the antics continued when the X
Games rolled around eg would go on to
win gold after a tight seven-game series
and sniped down did not let lethal
forget it after the X Games
CLG would win the HCS World Championship
a roster shake-up would follow for the
rest of the league and snipe down left
at Lee Joon snipe down went on to form a
dream team with envious ivory continued
number seven goes to double lift and
afro mu the relationship between
teammates is crucial to craft a
successful team in late 2015
see LG's League of Legends squad
underwent some massive changes as star
80 carry double if left the team to join
TSM leaving his longtime support afro mu
doublelift anaphora Moo were friends
holding down clg's botlane for three
years together the duo tag-teamed many
interviews and were widely considered
one of the best bot lanes in LCS history
calling themselves rush-hour doublelift
accused afro Moo of forcing an ultimatum
on CLG like the truth is afro went to
the org and he said it's either me or
him
referring to me and I'm not playing with
Peter next year the two players
continued to make comments back and
forth on stream and in postgame
interviews best decision moving forward
only because Peter
brings people down more often than not
B&C what you had a falling out are you
and I are still buddies no not really
but a falling out it's on my plate for
sure now the two have since made up even
bought laning together again at the
League of Legends all-star event in 2016
Reginald and Tryndamere didn't have the
most dramatic beef but certainly one of
the most impactful which is why it comes
in at number 6 on our list during the
2016 na LCS summer split TSM owner
Reginald spoke out on how riots major
patches affected Italy's Gerry Tony
swords team because the patches change a
lot and so when you own a team and the
patches change in a really unfavorable
way for your players then there's a
higher chance that you'll do bad and you
can get relegated so I've struck the
system works if you get relegated you're
done and because the challengers seen us
a week didn't get relegated you pretty
much lose everything so how did Riot
respond well co-founder mark Tryndamere
Merrill took to Reddit to explain
coining the very mean worthy phrase love
me some Reggie love me some Reggie but
if he's so concerned about the financial
health of his players maybe he should
spend more of the millions he has made
slash makes from League of Legends on
paying them instead of investing in
other eSports where he's losing money
Reggie is one of the generally good guy
team owners but when owners don't want
to shell out for top talent that's a
tricky problem we intentionally
prioritized game health and viewer
experience over the ability for team
slash coaches to field safer comps by
lane swapping the back-and-forth sparked
a bigger conversation within the league
arguably paving the way for na LCS
franchising coming in at number five
Sonic Fox versus perfect legend summer
jam 9 featured a Mortal Kombat X
match between sonic Fox and perfect
legend it started over a Twitter beef
and ended with sonic Fox mopping the
floor with perfect legend beating him
perfect legend followed up his 10 oh
loss by downplaying sonic Fox's win
claiming the original Twitter beef
centered around Fox's Aaron black versus
his kongou what I did say is I would
speak anyway tournament organizer Eric
biggie small quickly grabbed the mic
[Applause]
that's right immediately after the loss
of Big E made them play again Sonic
Fox's Erin black vs. perfect legends
Kung Lao and well this one ended in a
similar fashion to the games before it a
three round sweep and a final 1304
coming in at number four Starcraft 2
pros Huck and Indra the two players had
a history Huck was an up-and-comer at
the time just beginning his career in
Starcraft 2 while Adria was a veteran of
the scene starting his career early in
StarCraft brood war there developed a
patron
he's a piece of trash who wouldn't win
any games if he didn't play Protoss the
beef really peaked at MLG Dallas 2011
where their rivalry was perfectly
summarized by one play Edra left the
game Oh Huck used hallucinate avoid rays
to overwhelm Indra who left the game
thinking he'd lost of course the
hallucinations never dealt any actual
damage to Indra Huck was sure to bring
it up next game the two would continue
to battle until August of 2011 when Evil
Geniuses announced Huck was joining
their team finally putting to rest this
esports beef leffen and hungrybox is
relentless hate for each other comes in
at number three on this list leffen and
hungrybox are both super smash bros
melee players at the top of their eSport
they also really hate each other
hungrybox famously claims he only
attended Genesis 5 to kick leffen zas
high feeling about that it it was the
only reason I came to this tournament I
want to kick that guy that the two have
beefed in game and of course over
Twitter hbox also went on stream to
gloat about beating leffen at smash
seven five three one design and
published a video to his youtube from
his stream called one of the many
reasons to dislike hbox the saying that
like there's two types of people in this
world
one of the most infamous rivalries in
the fgc K Brad and Wolf Kron do not hold
back and that's why they are second on
this list of esports beefs their
particular beef began in 2016 when wolf
Kron wiped his hands of K Brad after
beating him in Street Fighter 5 at
frosty foul stinks 9 the beef escalated
online with tweets and Facebook posts
running rampant k Brad got his revenge
and at the Capcom Pro Tour he slammed
wolf thrown in a no respect has been
shown in this beef and the hatred
between the two is well this beef ever
end or is this everlasting now the
culmination of their beef thus far is
undoubtedly they're running at the
league's Street Fighter 5 I just can't
deal with I just don't know how you know
every excuses come out the book now as a
player I used to always fist bump him I
all used to always shake his hand until
he started talking trash but as a person
I just don't like him I just don't like
him straight up what are you thoughts on
that man
who gives a [ __ ] do to change things
here this tournament I mean I really
didn't do anything I mean it's kind of
fell a point for me after we be optic at
Columbus and I mean I don't wanna say
anything got boring but I was just kind
of focusing on other things but optic
gaming versus faze clan a tale of two
Call of Duty Giants tops our list of
eSports beefs the two would battle for
online turf
both producing similar YouTube content
in the early days of their respective
orgs optic would be the first to take on
eSports braving the rocky shores of the
early seen phase would eventually make
their debut in eSports bringing their
large fanbase with them to giants coming
from the same place now had an arena to
duke it out in while optic had a huge
head start phase was hot on their tail
UMG in the early days optic and faze
dominated the YouTube gaming the Mukul
there either liked optic or fails while
the phase and optic rivalry has calmed
down since the impact of this esports
beef can still be felt today well guys
if that wasn't some usda-approved choice
cut prime beef I don't know what is but
if you think there's an eSports beef
that should have been in our top 10 list
and wasn't well I got some bad news for
you you're just wrong
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button